It's been two weeks since you won
what has this period been like?
It's been such a joy! But
I've been sick.
And you might hear it in my voice.
I came home after a lot of rehearsals.
The pressure of having the lowest odds.
And
also the feeling of when I'd hit the last note ...
I felt that, ÇI may have won nowÈ.
Because it really felt awesome!
But wen that later becomes reality, and you get
eight 12's from the international jury
and Sweden's vote ...
That's quite a lot to process.
Yes!
And then your body just goes ...
Yes, a little like that.
The shop is closed?
The day after, I had to get up at eight.
After the after party.
Because we're filming a show that's called
ÇThe day afterÈ, which is about ...
Yeah, right!
Which is about what it feels like the day after.
And after that you get home to a two-year-old,
a four-year-old and a spouse.
ÇDAAAAD!È
And my body then said Çwait a minute nowÈ.
And I told my spouse and my children:
ÇI'm just going to rest for a little while.È
24 hours later
I wake up
and realise that I've been sleeping for 24 hours!
You slept for 24 hours?!
Yes. I was completely finished!
You spoke about your background. And your
childhood was here in London, actually.
You grew up here and lived here until you were six.
Correct.
If you were to do a flashback to
the schoolyard here in London
compared to the schoolyard in VŠxjš, where you moved.
Yes.
What is the difference?
The biggest difference is that you have the entire world in London.
When it comes to culture, colour and background.
And
I never understood that I was different.
Because everyone else was different in the schoolyard.
Everyone had different backgrounds, different clothes,
different colours.
And there was a culture shock when we came to VŠxjš.
Which is in the South of Sweden.
Yes, exactly, SmŒland.
VŠxjš has been fantastic in every way
and I have VŠxjš to thank in a lot of ways.
But going to school from grade one to six was ...
It was pretty tough for me, because I was
the only one who had dark skin
in that particular schoolyard, in contradiction to London.
And those were tough years.
And that was partly about the n-word.
When I heard that for the first time
I didn't understand what it was.
And I run home to my parents
up the hill, open the door
and I remember it like it was yesterday.
My parents are sitting at the kitchen table, eating together.
And my name is Jompa at home, not John, Jompa.
And I come in and say:
ÇMom and dad, what does 'fucking negro' mean?È
And their glance in that second
said more than a thousand words.
Because they knew that
ÇOkay. You're going to go through this kind of period now.È
And having kids myself
I dread that period, if it will happen to my children.
But it was ...
It was such a powerful memory, because I had never experienced
that it was negative being different.
Because that little six year old boy
just wanted to play football
and be just like everyone else.
As loved as everyone else.
Is there any of them ...
Is there any of them you remember that you can't let go of?
Of the bullies?
No, I usually say: ÇKill'em with a smileÈ.
And ...
And
in one way it's like Çlook at me now, I was rightÈ!
But ...
But what became the turning point, when did it turn around, when did it end?
I called it Çthe race that changed my lifeÈ.
We had a sports day at school.
And I had dressed up so nicely, I had tights on, and a tank top!
And I had glasses with a granny chain so they wouldn't fall down!
I was ready for war!
And the people I was running against, they were the ones who had been the meanest.
And in some way
I was running for my life, but also as a relief
because when I crossed the finish line
I was so far ahead.
I won.
And for the first time, I was best at something.
I had beat them at something.
Everything turned then, because I had gained my identity through sports.
You got Swedish Championship medals in both in the junior and youth championships.
Yes, correct.
What would you say was your biggest accomplishment?
Wow. That probably is that I quit!
But BEFORE that!
I would probably say my personal record of 10.84.
It was one of those runs where everything felt right.
You were 23 when you
chose music instead, you had been doing music all along.
And then you went to Stockholm, and you wanted to pursue music.
And a lot of people said no.
Yes. I would say I had probably 50-60 CDs
made. They were hand written.
And with the last CD
I knocked on Jšrgen Elofsson's door.
At Lidingš.
Who is a very well-known songwriter.
Yes, it's one of the biggest we have.
And I knocked the door, drew a big breath, I had no money in my pocket
because I had spent everything on a taxi, one had to take taxi to be fancy!
And I knocked on the door
and I think that he saw someplace in my eyes that
if this guy has traveled out here and done this
he must want this quite a lot.
So he said: ÇWell, young boy, you have one minute
from nowÈ. He has a SkŒne dialect.
Sorry, Jšrgen.
And then I had to try to find my coolness and insert the CD in the player.
And I manage to in the end and
Jšrgen presses play.
And he stops the CD after a while
and he literally says:
ÇYeah. Have you written this?È
ÇYes.È I'm sitting in a chair.
ÇOkay.È And he starts playing it again.
And he presses pause.
ÇIt's like a nicely wrapped poo!È
And
the panic at this point is very overwhelming.
But afterwords he asks: ÇWho is singing?È
ÇWho is singing?È in Swedish.
And I take a deep breath and say:
ÇI'm the one who is singing.È
And he says: ÇBe here at 11 tomorrow.È
I have a job for you.
So I became his personal demo singer.
And started recording his hits,
his demos, all around Europe,
and in Stockholm.
The first highlight in your music career
after having knocked on doors and fought a long time
was that you together with Jšrgen Elofsson
got to write a song
ordered by prince Daniel.
Yes.
For the wedding of Victoria and Daniel.
What was that like for your parents?
We had a confidentiality agreement.
Because I did travel to VŠxjš to my parents
and my brother.
And we were sitting in the living room, and it's like a scene from a TV show.
We're sitting there watching these fantastic people who are getting married, with everything that's happening.
And then it's time for the wedding.
ÇI'm standing by an angel ...È
And the text appears with
our names.
Right, because it says the title of the song!
Yes! ÇWritten by!È
And my mom goes:
And my dad tries to play it cool, but even he is like:
In some kind of shock mode.
So they completely lost it.
They couldn't believe it was true!
But that's what happened.
And then you've also written the British contribution
Yes!
Thank you.
That's a slightly different song.
Can you give us a little taste of how it goes?
Yes, if you behave nicely!
I'm very nice!
But it's pretty simple.
Sorry.
You have ...
You have made it very hard for yourself.
Thank you for that!
You're going to compete against yourself!
Yes.
In Tel Aviv.
Who is going to win?
Sweden will win!
John, thank you for being here tonight!